في هذه المأدبة الفخمة للزعيم
الأعلى للذكرى الخامسة والسبعين للجيش الكوري الشمالي
كيم جونغ أون مع زوجته وفتاة تبلغ من
العمر تسع سنوات تقريبًا فتاة
يقول البعض إنها يمكن أن تكون الشخص المختار الذي
يتم إعداده ليكون الزعيم الكوري الشمالي القادم
من خلال إظهار بعض الجودة  مع
ابنته ، بدا الأمر وكأنه يريد
عرض عائلته على أنها عائلة جيدة ومستقرة كما
يقول ، ولإظهار نفسه
كقائد للناس العاديين ، فإن
حياتها ليست سوى اسمها الطبيعي
كيم جوي في سن المدرسة الابتدائية التي
تفوقت عليها بالفعل.  غرفة مليئة بكبار
الضباط العسكريين ،
وصفتها وسائل الإعلام الحكومية في كوريا الشمالية
بأنها ابنة كيم المحترمة ، وحظيت
بحفاوة بالغة عندما وصفت صديقي بأنه صديقي ، لقد
تعلمنا اسمها لأول
مرة من دنيس رودمان ، الصديق الذي عاش في
كرة السلة مرة واحدة ، كيم ادعى أنه
يجب عليه الاحتفاظ بها.  الأميرة ذات الحجم الصغير في
عام 2013 عندما كانت طفلة قبل بضعة أشهر ،
جعلت ابنة كيم
تكشف وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الكبيرة عن اختبار صواريخ باليستية عابرة للقارات في
مطار بيونغ يانغ لتفقد
أرسنال والدها في أرسنال ،
يمكنها يومًا ما قيادة
مصدر لديه معرفة عميقة
بالشمال.  القيادة الكورية من خلال
المياه الباردة على فكرة أن هذا كان خليفة ،
وكشفت لشبكة CNN أنه من السابق لأوانه
تقديم أي افتراضات أو التحدث عن أي
خليفة محتمل بالتأكيد إنها
إشارة واضحة يرسل الرئيس كيم إلى
العالم التزامًا ثابتًا بحماية
عائلته ومستقبله.  الأجيال مع
البرنامج النووي إذا تم اختيارها ، فستكون
أول أنثى والجيل الرابع
من قيادة عائلة كيم مثل والدها
وجدها ، وصيغة
الأسرة للسيطرة على الخوف ودعاية
حملة العلاقات العامة المصممة بعناية
تشيد بقوة قادة المستقبل
وببراعة الخليفة  يمكن أن يكون فتى أو
فتاة أصغر أو أكبر ، بغض النظر عن
المهمة الوحيدة التي تحمل
ثروة عائلة كيم وقوتها
لفترة ، بينما كان يُنظر إلى أخت كيم الصغرى كيم يو
جونغ على أنها الخليفة المحتمل لكيم في نهاية المطاف ،
وهي معروفة بخطبها
النارية التي وجهتها ذات يوم.
القوات المسلحة في البلاد
لتفجير مكتب اتصال مشترك بالقرب من الحدود
الآن أنظار العالم على
ابنة كيم الخبراء الذين يقومون بتحليل كل صورة
وكل مقال بحثًا عن أدلة حول
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي القادم
المحتمل كل ذلك قبل عيد ميلادها العاشر.